and the number of people killed by
tsunami-like flooding in eastern Libya
has crossed six thousand heavy rainfall
on Sunday caused two dams to burst in
the city of derna a wall of water then
descended on coastal towns washing many
people out to sea or burying them in
debris and landslides aid from Libya's
two rival governments has been sent to
distribution centers International
search and rescue teams are also now on
the ground
the head of the presidential Council in
Tripoli has asked the prosecutor General
to open an investigation into the derna
floods they want to look into whether
there were any mistakes or negligence
which led to the collapse of these two
dams Hussein Sweden explains the level
of the destruction in Libya
one of the main reasons for the
increased number of deaths is the
collapse of the derna valley Dam which
swept all the residential buildings
nearby the area that's totally destroyed
is estimated at 900 000 square meters
five Bridges have also collapsed which
isolated the Cities East and West the
area that was heavily damaged is
estimated to be around 3 million square
meters
satellite images show just how much was
lost in the flooding take a look this
was derna on September 2nd a city of
about 80 000 people there are four
bridges that cross the Wadi Darna River
including a main one along the
Waterfront if you look there it's
circled now the city looks like this
the river which is dry for most of the
Year overflowed and it destroyed an
entire section of derna both the bridges
and the buildings and silt has spread
all across the city
a Malik trainer joins us from Tripoli
Malik what's happening in derna now I
understand the search for survivors is
all but over so what's the priority now
like you said Cyril I mean with every
passing hour the chances of pulling out
survivors uh decreases tremendously and
it's starting to look like a recovery
operation so officials tell us that the
body counts of of people dead so far is
around six thousand I spoke to a
gentleman in dunno yesterday and he said
more than 2 400 were buried in the city
just just yesterday in Mass Graves uh
and and thousands more were swept into
the sea and are missing uh so people
officials are expecting uh the the the
death toll to continue to rise
tremendously
all right Malik standby we want to give
an important piece of context here and
I'll come right back to you Libya
plunged into violence in 2011. after
after his longtime leader Muammar
Gaddafi was toppled since then it's had
two rival administrations in the west
there is the UN recognized government
led by prime minister Abdul Hamid deba
in Tripoli it controls those areas that
you see there in blue Osama Hamad the
prime minister in the East leads a rival
Administration that's known as the House
of Representatives and that one is
backed by the Libyan warlord Khalifa
haftar the areas in red are under his
control and the Rival sides have failed
to unify for years now elections were
scheduled for December 2021 they never
happened because of differences on
candidates among other sticking points
Malik back to you so in a normal
situation the government would allocate
funds organize teams and then start
rebuilding spend the money Etc but in
this case the internationally recognized
government as we just laid out is in the
western of the country and the most
affected areas are in the East so how's
that going to work
well we've just received news that a
ministerial delegation including the uh
better al-tumi he's the minister of
local governance has arrived in eastern
Libya also the head of the emergency
committee appointed here in the west uh
David Wright arrived in eastern Libya
they're currently headed to al-beda and
from there to devna so they're going to
assess the situation uh what we're
seeing Cyril is is people coming
together with the people of Libya who
have been divided for years are uniting
and trying to do whatever they can to
help the people in need in eastern Libya
as far as the governments I mean I I
spoke to the minister of transportation
yesterday and he told me I know I asked
him about the coordination between the
Rival governments and he said right now
it's not about politics we need to come
together as a people to help to help
those in need my mother trained a
reporting from Tripoli thank you very
much for all of that context